so are you guys sick of these crazy long
trailers every time you go to the movies
you get like 1820 trailers I know
Alonso's probably not but you sit there
for like 45 minutes or an hour before
the movie actually starts well the
National Association of theater owners
have released a set of optional
guidelines to the studios movie trailers
shouldn't be longer than two minutes 30
seconds shorter than the standard right
now trailer should not be shown more
than five months from the film's release
theaters would give each distributor two
exceptions a year on both of these rules
and guidelines are technically voluntary
and apply to titles opening on or after
October first so i have to stress here
again these this is voluntary nobody has
to do this these are just guidelines
that they're saying maybe you want to do
this if you want to make the movie going
experience a little more enjoyable but i
have a feeling you love sitting there
and probably so they're all day watching
trailer actually i really hate trailers
I yeah well I'm spoiled because most of
the movies I go see our are you know
advance screenings for critics they
don't have trailers on them as a as a
general rule but sometimes they're
movies that don't get shown to us you
know I did I had to pay to see i
frankenstein you know and so and then
yeah imma stop to how many trailers they
are there are how long they are how much
they give away it's got the point where
I I almost want to just leave the room
because I feel like I try not to know
about movies going in I come in with his
blankets late as possible and trailers
want to show you the whole shebang
before you walk in the theater so the US
i guess so that it are too becomes it's
like you're seeing its own sequel by the
time you see the actual film a pasar
that we live in a time where
everything's becoming shorter and
quicker and yet trailer seem like
they're getting longer they even
something like the the plan of the apes
equal that's coming out i saw the
trailer on youtube for that and it's
like you've given me everything like i
get like all they'd say was more monkeys
and if you know shits gonna go down it's
just the whole wedge of pre-show
advertising is crazy I mean I if I went
to movies more often I would just be
kind of horrified by how much you have
to sit there I mean you go to an AMC
theater before the movie even starts are
already running that first look thing
you know with a talking to people on the
new TNT drama or whatever and then the
lights go down and then it's more ads
and more trailers as like don't forget
trivia you got the trade yeah exactly
word scramble right bank rarefied get to
the [ __ ] movie already so what I'm
missing it like okay I'm gonna ask the
the the movie expert where's the benefit
for these uh these movie theaters I mean
ID is the the the production contributed
to play more of the movie that like you
said show whole damn thing so if you
think it would rate it co-op diminishing
returns well I think actually trailers
have gotten longer and I think what they
figured out is that people are more
inclined to buy a ticket to something
that they know what they're getting than
a pig in a poke and so that's why that's
why so movies are sequels and remakes
and retreads and reboots because there's
a familiarity there and then if there
isn't a familiarity if you saw the
trailer you're familiar you know and so
I if it didn't work they wouldn't do it
so clearly they figured out it that it
works but I mean this has been an
ongoing thing ever back in the nineties
douglas coupland referring to Winnebagos
which work really big trailers you know
uh and so I I obviously from marketing
standpoint they're getting something out
of it but I think that it I can
understand why the theaters are annoyed
with it and I as a as an occasional you
know consumer ticket buyer of movies I'm
also annoying so we got the pro movie
guy's opinion on this I I hate them I I
sit there and I'm thank God for twitter
because I just pay no attention to any
of them uh but but what do you do when
you sit there I mean you've paid 15
bucks probably to get in there right
then you get the commercials you've
already paid for popcorn and soda and
the TNT first look at all a sub are you
angry like sometimes I'm actually angry
by the time there's there's times when I
was watching and I see some trailer
oceany good I won't see that but I've
first I'll have a really bad memory and
I see is the most embarrassing Pike two
movies a year and and you don't know
what they are it's not because I don't
like going once a man like i wanna do
this so much more a job don't I don't
set aside the time my brain to do so
once I'm there it changes every time
because it's from last year's last time
I went and I sit like oh they change
that not to oh [ __ ] this is really
getting along and the last time when I
took my son he's too to see frozen
because it was the only child like
enough movie and I was like let's take a
satyr after let's go catch a matinee so
I can only spend 20 lines
okay so we're sitting there and I'm
thinking is his first movie going
experience I don't know if he's going to
last it's dark it's loud it's really
like it's a big experience so I said
we'll see if he makes it to the first 45
minutes it's a win and we said it was a
full Mickey Mouse movie that went in
from all such a short subject which I'd
like you know the thing I was like this
is good but we're not gonna make to this
movie a ticking time bomb meanwhile you
fell asleep II probably don't know that
my oh my gosh i would be down for more
short subjects like either that cartoon
is attached to frozen get a horse is
brilliant the value no more of that
river yeah but the trailers I mean
you're actually sat in audiences where
they gets like the fourth or fifth
trailer and you hear people go uh like
oh come on start the damn movie already
like everybody in the theater is just
just feels drained already right so in a
day and age when we have netflix and HBO
go and all the streams of how much
longer until everything is released at
once and you'll just have to pay a
premium if you want to just get it
streamed at home because that to me
seems like what the future will be if
you've got the money we'll just at home
you don't even have to go out and deal
with all the people in the popcorn in
the first are we were we're we're
inching in that direction I mean there's
already what they call day and date uh
for a lot of indie movies and smaller
films and even a lot of those films get
are made available on VOD two or three
weeks but a month before they come out
the energy them yeah I'll school then
and although I don't watch movies that
often isn't it nice to sit in the
theater get also i always prefer see on
the big screen but boy they make it
difficult with all the advertised and
the trailers and so it's only people who
maybe can create their own movie
experience at home would really take
that in you know there's some people
questioning about athletes and actors
and musicians who have check out this
home theater miles like that's nice yep
but the new the new big TVs you know
have that sort of stuff Sony 4k which is
the same thing you're getting in your
movie theater and if you you know if
you're the small of multiplex are in a
large enough living room you start
becoming the same thing yeah
you can make your own movie trailers for
before if you're so inclined side my
favorite of that of those lists of non
rules yes his yet if I was the five
months before move out because then
again I see it so Mike what is gonna be
all miss it coming out summer 2017
remember always like I'm not even gonna
be alive at that one what day or they
were you Lisa you're gonna be seeing
that same trailer a good 10 more times
over the next two years yeah exactly and
again these are all voluntary things so
most likely none of this will ever come
to fruition